يجب أن تكون هذه واحدة من أهم
السيارات التي صنعتها مرسيدس بنز على
الإطلاق وهذا يقول الكثير لأن
صانع السيارات الألماني كان يصنع السيارات
لفترة أطول من أي شركة على وجه الأرض الآن
تدخل الصناعة حقبة جديدة وعلى الرغم من أن
هذه ليست مرسيدس  أول سيارة كهربائية
هي بالتأكيد السيارة الأكثر أهمية
إذا كان هناك قمة في
سيارة السيدان الألمانية الكبيرة الفاخرة التي يجب أن تكون
مرسيدس بنز الفئة S ،
فهذه هي مرسيدس بنز إي كيو
مثل الفئة S ولكنها كهربائية بالكامل
كل الفخامة مع جميع التقنيات
والأداء الأفضل ، لذا فإن
مرسيدس التي تم رفعها للتو لم تضع
البطاريات في فئة S بالطبع ، فإن
eqs هي سيارة مختلفة تمامًا
مصممة ومتناسبة
كسيارة كهربائية كبيرة بالكامل
هذه السيارة هي بالفعل i  يمكن أن
يخبرك بمتعة أكبر في القيادة مقارنة
بسيارة مرسيدس الفئة S التي تعمل بالغاز ، وهي سيارة eqs 450 بالإضافة إلى الإصدار الأقل قوة الذي
يحتوي على محرك كهربائي بقوة 329
حصانًا يقود العجلات الخلفية
، ويحتوي eqs 580 على محركين محرك واحد
توفر العجلات الأمامية والأخرى الخلفية
مجتمعة قوة 516 حصانًا ،
وتقدم eqs نطاقًا يصل إلى 350 ميلًا ،
وتكون قمرة القيادة مباشرة من
مركبة فضائية ،
فأنا أحب الإضاءة داخل هذه
السيارة والإضاءة المحيطة بهذه الخطوط الملونة
التي تجعلها تبدو لطيفة  مثل السبعينيات
أو الديسكو ،
يمكن تخصيصها مثل
مجموعة كاملة من الألوان المختلفة بالإضافة إلى
أنها يمكن أن تتغير تلقائيًا جنبًا
إلى جنب مع كيفية استخدامك
لدواسة الوقود والفرامل
، تبدو مرسيدس التي تسمى شاشة فائقة السرعة
أكبر شاشة تعمل باللمس في  أي
سيارة إنتاج ،
لكنها في الحقيقة مجرد ثلاث شاشات تحت
قطعة زجاجية واحدة تبدو رائعة ،
لكنني شخصياً أفضل لوحة
جلدية كلاسيكية بشكل عام ، واجهة السائق
جيدة جدًا مع الكثير من
الميزات المفيدة ،
تمتلك الكثير من السيارات الكهربائية دي جي ما
يسمونه  الجبهة أو الجذع الأمامي
ليس معادل كل هذا مجرد
أشياء ميكانيكية وإلكترونية هنا ،
لا يمكنك حتى فتح غطاء المحرك ،
يجب أن يقوم فني مرسيدس الخاص بك بذلك
إذا كنت قلقًا بشأن
مساحة التخزين المفقودة في المقدمة
، فما عليك سوى النظر في الخلف ، فإن eqs عبارة عن هاتشباك مثل سيارات
الدفع الرباعي ولديها مساحة تخزين بحجم سيارات الدفع الرباعي
خلف المقاعد الخلفية ،
لذلك بالطبع تحتوي eqs على
مقابض الأبواب المتدفقة التي من المفترض
لتخرج عندما تقترب من السيارة
أو تضغط عليها ، فإن المشكلة الوحيدة هي
أنهم نادرًا ما يعملون
، حيث تتحول صناعة السيارات إلى
محرك كهربائي وبعيدًا عن
محركات الاحتراق الداخلي
التي ساعدتها مرسيدس بنز في الريادة منذ أكثر من
قرن ، سيكون من السهل على مرسيدس
لتضيع وتتخلف عن الركب بينما يتغير العالم كله من
حوله ،
لكن المعادلات تظهر أن مرسيدس مستعدة للقتال على الأقل